this is the theme the theme alaikum our
next the next part of our show is
actually the dance show we're very proud
to have brother Eddie red civic here
Eddie is the founder of the popular teen
show he's the host and founder the teen
show is a Muslim film company that
strives to provide authentic information
on Islam from the quran and sunnah and
absolutely stays away from all negative
and extreme topics or or positions in
the slam that are not based upon the
sunda and we're very happy to have
brother Eddie here tonight to have the
Dean show live from the new york city
muslim center and as part of the
foundation for knowledge and development
like that invite brother Eddie up to the
stage this is the thing
this is the video this is the things of
Athene jus this is the things that angel
this is the thing you this is the
whoever lives on something he will die
on that thing and whoever dies on
certain thing will be raised upon that
thing so what are you living for and
what are you living on so from the right
to the left introduce yourself and
introduce yourself and we'll begin with
me I want some questions at you so okay
so I wanna call my name is back here
I've been taking a class at the
foundation since the associate degrees
program has opened up back in 2010 and i
have to say there has been a blessing my
stomach do back in college that when i
graduated there will be something that I
can go and learn the religion a lot of
us don't have the opportunity to go
overseas and you know from the light
soon as I graduated the associate's
degrees program open up so very happy
about her hi my name is karim hassan
similar situation i've been soon as the
foundation for some of their courses
weekend seminars and i started becoming
a full-time sooner at their associates
degree program which also as a crow
mentioned in 2010 hamdullah have been
here ever since and it's been a great
blessing from Allah know now in the
video we saw it talked about getting
hooked how did you get hooked up with
the program it's actually a funny story
how this all began me Zacher and I we
actually used to help volunteering which
they zakir naik soccer and I soccer and
I we used to help volunteer for the
foundation I originally learned about
the Arabic seer program this Arabic
program because of he had a status up I
forgot which source it was either his
facebook or twitter so i asked them
about it having learned about it we
decided to go into it and we weren't
really into the other courses yet so
once we came and started volunteering we
started sitting down in the courses and
we were hooked right off the bat it was
originally we were just focus on arabic
and then one day what i've registered to
this class and we like I weekend with
any of these classes again yes like that
yes like that you got a bit by the good
bugs so we did hungry less so what are
some of these courses yes so since we
began we've taken numerous courses last
semester which of course got hooked
basic based on addictions
that you know people can face we took
the thick of Sola learning exactly how
to pray exactly like the prophet
salallahu alayhi wasallam parade I'm
starting from the beginning we took a
course on that hereafter a la farà we
took a course on the preservation of the
Quran and Sunnah we took the thick of
purification we take an imam now is
forty hadith we've taken family matters
which was a course on Family Development
husband and wife relations we took tests
here hamdullah and now you know for this
semester now we're taking he is the
names and attributes of Allah as origin
an Alpina course and I'm glad it's a
great blessing what's the methodology of
the Academy that they use that really
also interests you it keeps it flowing
it's not is it boring do you sometimes
that's it really you mentioned that you
got revoked and its your right right
interesting so what's the methodology
that the teachers you just to keep you
coming back for more and for more from
when you're here now talking about it ya
want more yeah yeah hamdullah it's
completely different than any other
islamic educational experience that I've
ever had you know we're sitting here in
a class which has been continuously
given it's a continuous procedure where
we're coming every single week to learn
a formula we have students that are
dedicated to do this on top of that the
instructors Michelle they're very
intriguing they're very grabbing their
intellectually you know you're engaged
intellectually in your classroom setting
you're not just sitting there and the
instructor than understanding that you
know talking as fast as you can and
you're not just jotting down notes
you're actually sitting there in
structure ask you questions and grabs
your attention the whole class they're
trying to figure out the answer and by
the end of the class you've actually
learned without even without even
realizing it so it's a very entertaining
process also you're always constantly
like mine I call them brain candy it's a
fun experience marine cameo yeah yeah
homeland I would definitely say
something that separates you know what
the foundation uses in their methodology
is the the ability to have interaction
the interactions with our teachers in
that a lot of times you know I've taken
previous Islamic courses we didn't have
the freedom to just ask our instructor
right away a question or we didn't have
that connection with them from the low
here we do have that you know we have
the numbers of our instructors if we
wanted to ask them something we go to
eat with them it's a whole
really one of a greater picture so the
instructors are cool oh yeah I'm not
very well as vanilla ok any memorable
moments so that you guys had to see like
to share with the audience dad there's a
lot of dating from the 2010 when we took
a left or the hereafter one of our
classes in the middle of the semester
the instructors actually brought out a
wooden casket and put the wooden casket
out so the reality you know hit us right
there people actually got in the casket
yeah it's kind of a scary experience
that's a memorable yeah it really was
and you know going through the semesters
when we were doing mm no he's 40 hadith
you know we had the hadith of Prophet
sallallaahu are they who said them where
he says every joint in the body you know
give it to do southwark ah so the truck
has brought out a Skeletor skeleton
model one student had to go up to the
skeleton and start counting the joints
he was counting them on the hand he
reached 30 40 and he only had the hands
panel ah so you know to really realize
the hadith and understand its meaning
you know we were able to see it visually
let's let's back it up a little bit you
talked about the casket yeah okay and
how did this work out so they bring out
the cast well we're sitting in class we
have the casket was ok this was a
surprise ya know no one had any idea it
was just like this setting and everyone
is hitting this is the future box that
all of us here does have a disagreement
no matter what meth have your on it
doesn't matter no matter where you're
coming from black white Chinese nautilus
and Muslim we can all agree that we're
all going to die any disagreements okay
so talk to us this I mean this is what's
this what this is what woke me up death
the reality that we're all going to die
so we better be in the best state by
developing our but ourselves would be
the best that we can be according to
God's will not our desires so it
described that moment you see the casket
it was suffocating it was so small I
were like what the hell you see it on
you actually got in it uh yeah it's a
very tight space you watch on TV you
know these people with huge caskets they
are all dressed up but this not what
happens you know in reality the casket
is very small once the cover is closed
it's it's pitch-black it's uh you have
no breathing room and that's what's
going to happen to us and you know one
thing that really caught me was that
let's say when you know someone we know
passes away we have in our mind say that
we're going to go to the graves we're
going to be seeing
when we're sitting in the middle of the
class and this was brought out it was
just like that like everything came to a
halt and that's you know possibly how
our death could be the entire class was
was very surprised and it was a very
scary expense with the entire class I
remember students you know when stepping
away because they were in shock and what
is this and you get that feeling you
know you go to the gym you go to the gym
to get the pump the good feeling you
know the Bloods flowing you start
feeling like okay you know energized so
we look for that feeling some people
they go to the nightclub to get that
feeling I all those you know useless
feelings a lot of all right you know
chasing your lesson your desires and you
do drugs to get a certain feeling
alcohol to get a food certain feeling
then you got the negative side of things
Yeah right what was that feeling was did
you feel the feeling that feeling of
reality it's like a wake up that's how
you can describe that's exactly how you
can describe it a feeling of reality a
wake up call it was just a scary moment
it was just like your heart would skip a
few beats just by looking at them now
someone says man why do you what do
these guys are crazy what are these guys
doing bring in a casket and where they
teach it what were what are the benefits
of this I would say that the benefits
are for the Muslims to come to the
realization that they will pass and to
make sure that what they're going to do
before that is going to be favorable to
them on the day of judgment so we want
to prepare we want to be the best human
being absolutely and we want to worship
the one who created us not his creation
and do good deeds absolutely what what
motivates us is death right house that
day a judgment has come and see the
paradise or that hot place we don't want
to be in the Hellfire yes next question
tell us now you know this is what I love
because the Quran the verbatim literal
word of God the stories over and over
and he's a mullah buys me tell us this
is these are things that inspire us true
stories and over and over ibrahima Lisa
Abraham know what Jesus their work their
Dawa calling the people to submit not to
themselves of the crazy but to submit to
the Creator Dawa so is there any
training of because again is because we
Aslam says love all mankind so we love
mankind that's why we need to share the
purpose of life so is there any training
for dice for
well now to get out there because it's
not about you know learning this just
keep it to ourselves you got an antidote
and people need the medicine is there
any training to how to deliver the
message of purpose of life to the people
in this classroom i would say that
there's two major parts to the
foundation that we have here which is
knowledge and development so we the
students we do obtain the knowledge here
and you know the show you can our
instructors the the but the students
here we call them super students and
these super students are taken to the
side under the wing you know for example
under shake shakeel under his wing and
personally trained on a one-on-one basis
and you know this is done so that we can
help our communities we could start
calling people to Islam you know starts
within ourselves we have to start
developing ourselves and once we're at
that state where we can help others we
begin to do that you know for example in
our message adhere mejor de said no
Miriam the last three weeks the last
three fridays each gemara was led by a
foundation student each of the three
foot bus we're given by a foundation
student from the LA this is a facility
and this is a program where we're able
to get the knowledge and put it into
application not only for us for the
community and it's not something that we
come to get a class for now and we go
home no we actually use this knowledge
and we develop ourselves and our
families and our communities and you
know from though you can't find this
anywhere so from those is a great
blessing Masha all of us I was wondering
every one thing was my Bonjour he once
said that he give us example of Pharaoh
from and he was saying that loss mahanta
you know gave him so many tests and so
many chances and he softened our hearts
with that with that comment stating that
you know nobody we know can equal to the
evil of her from who claimed it was gone
and so that's how we should we interact
with our with individuals you know no
matter how many times we feel like oh
they're not listening to us or they're
you know we don't care which are hard to
be soft soft and so that's what we get
both aspects also personally why is it
training us to be a little bit software
towards anybody was speaking to
implementing that other and just a guess
cream said give me the dollar I'm gonna
move on to you talk to us about this
Arabic program as their you you signed
up for why'd you sign up for
ok so the Arabic su programa we start
back two thousand are you an air are you
Arab yes I'm not our concern the
subcontinent and before I r week say you
know if I Bosnia know the subcontinent
India no no I'm are you from under all
right so what basically I would say you
know I believe like everybody who's
interested in Arabic they go to probably
a few phases when I started off I start
off with self-study you know maybe I
couldn't write back on my own I have to
you know I can't afford this right into
the game of time etc but that doesn't
work out then you go move on to
something else you try it like a
university-level Arabic and fine you
take semesters of university level
Arabic what do you learn you know you
learn how to say hello how are you you
know I have a house here I'm from here I
go to this school but you don't know how
you open up the Quran you know maybe one
word you know like what that's all you
would know and so that that curriculum
is not focused on during the Quran or
understanding the crime and as Muslims
that's our goal why do we learn Arabic
you know RV wouldn't be considered a
language to learn if it wasn't for the
Quran and we wonder we learn how to be
just to learn this and the Quran to
please Allah and to get closer to Allah
and so that's why once I think when
starting on a mixer program the program
itself is focused on a by the time you
finish eighty-five percent of the Quran
you have to understand it you will
understand inshallah and from the first
from the first recall it from the first
day from the first session when you
learn those words and you review the
words and you just feel an attachment to
those words to the surah that has those
words and when you recite the soda you
are very you're very happy you're just
feeling in you hard like oh I understand
what allah saying to me and it's not
just somebody else's word it's a lot
speaking to so that's the reason why our
bricks it's working it's not it's not
insensible math should we again you know
you walk out forgetting almost
everything you learn this is something
that's continuous on a weekly basis and
it's not it's not suffocate it you take
your time and you learn like it's not
suffocated yes why not just relax more
questions you're almost out of time I
love to spend more time with you guys
and wrong
we have another I understand guess we
have to bring up but in the short time
that we do have tell us why not just
rely on the translation you have Yusuf
Ali I material sorry international
absolutely like you mentioned all these
are those translators one of the reasons
why is like for example if you have a
painting you painted a picture or we
take a picture of something beautiful
and you call me up on the phone you
describe it to me it's not the same
thing as me being there in person and
seeing that object right so same thing
with the translation of the Quran the
Quran was sent by Allah Subhan Allah
Ta'ala and has two purposes it has a
purpose of guidance and the purpose of
of a miracle so what can I translator do
can they can they translate the miracle
of the Quran they really cannot and they
cannot translate the guidance to the
full extent they can do what they can
and in their abilities so what we're
really seeing it's not really the Quran
it's really the interpret to the
interpretation of somebody who who knows
how to translate the Quran so in the
back of your mind you kind of lose that
connectivity with Allah you don't
realize that Allah is a speaker but
speakers pixel or the speaker is used on
the speaker is a Muslim lost and con so
the it's not the translation itself it's
not considered the crime that's the most
of the loan amount agree and just by
during the transition you don't have
this connection it's not the same thing
the name of the software that you guys
use talk about this for a month okay so
it's basically a web application yeah
where you can access it from any laptop
and internet access your phones also can
access this and most of the work is done
at home where you access the whole thing
is based on a movie so you start off
with a script which is basically yours
that you're memorizing right so you
memorize the words then you get a value
a to see if you learn and during the
time of evaluation they ask you you know
in English what is this word you have to
type it in oughta be so not only are you
learning how to say the word you also
learning how to type the word and then
how to type with an arabic keyboard once
that's done you move on to the dialogue
or the the script person speaks
paragraphs to you stating this is what's
going on and basically all these words
that are used in this dialogue or from
the quran or from select surah so that's
how you learn the words that's how you
become connected to the words and once
again once the dialogue is done you get
a set of questions you get an evaluation
and the questions are not like oh you
can rephrase the question to get the
answer it's actually abstract they'll
ask a question what's going on in a
situation you have to reply
back in with the correct answer so
that's basically you go in steps and you
do this a few times and by the end of it
when you're done you can evaluate it by
a mentor so this isn't now this to
assets your student your MNT then the
person was helping you who's guiding you
through this is the mentor basically
what happens is again you go at your own
pace at home you don't have to go
there's no pressure there's no rush but
once you're ready to move on you you
contact your mentor and you get
evaluated and then you move on now well
the way the system works especially well
is if you get stumped you have somebody
you can contact you can also contact the
rest of the students via forum the that
you can contact the instructor the
mentors like text cell phone they're all
moderated but it does its job so you
never left alone and it's just like I
said you're never alone and it's always
a constant learning process and you guys
busy with yeah absolutely what we're
busy we have you know it's not like we
have to dedicate an hour every single
day to do this you have our time gap you
go ahead and do it it's not time
consuming it's really fun and you know
instead of watching TV that's what you
can do yeah so you guys are making time
I'm sure you got your wives and your
kids and everything and you guys well
neither one yet for both of us but
inshallah bless you you guys not married
yet what you wish Shaquille he's gotta
work on just happen a lot everybody's
good to see you guys so we got some the
development process yeah shall I bless
you with righteous wives I mean if I
said sure like I just want to add one
with them before we go a lot of the
stuff I want to ask the last one of the
blessed the people behind it the staff
the developers the mentors also they
spend a lot of the time they spent their
blood their sweat the tears into this
program and it really shows because the
students really learn from this it's
only in the last minute that we have 30
seconds each what would you like to say
to those that are stuck at home playing
the xbox and many who are just wasting
their time and not realizing the
importance of purpose of life not really
reflecting and sometimes you know they
come to jummah maybe roma down rolls
around and they get involved and they
step back but then they see you guys
young guys you're not
you know 60 years old doing this you
guys are young guys you're motivated you
know you're excited how can you how can
we get them excited just a few words
talk to us okay so basically for the
Xbox are out there it's fine to play
xbox about this and you gotta dedicate
time for you know there's a certain time
for certain things what other things is
you're going to feel an empty feeling in
your life you know you're missing
something and that's what the xbox is
there it's kind of trying to fill that
void if you want to fill that void it's
it's a lot it's not the xbox so finally
one in ten your friends your family
that's okay but at the end of the day
you have to focus that you have to
realize you're going to die you're going
to see Allah and what are you going to
say to him when you get there you know
you have to have something to back you
up basically right advice and I would
say you know to the brothers and sisters
perhaps struggling out there no one is
telling you to be an email no one is
telling you to be right right off the
bat a community leader it starts off
small so start off small do something
consistently and inshallah from this you
know you can develop yourself may Allah
reward you bless you and grant legolas
in this life and hereafter that going
thank you very much
this is the theme show this is the theme